good morning Hank it's Tuesday thanks
for your excellent video about Hillary
Clinton and Bernie Sanders tax plans
today I'm going to discuss the tax plans
put forth by Donald Trump and Ted Cruz I
would talk about John Kasich
tax plan but he hasn't put out a
detailed one yet so I can't okay but
first a brief overview of the federal
budget for which these taxes pay about a
third of the u.s. is three point eight
trillion dollar federal budget goes to
Social Security and unemployment mostly
to Social Security which provides income
for elderly and disabled people 27
percent goes to health care spending
this is mostly Medicare our publicly
funded health insurance program for the
elderly 16 percent goes to the military
six percent to service the national debt
four percent of veterans benefits and
after that the pieces of the pie start
to get pretty small so as you pointed
out last week taxes aren't any fun
they're also very very complicated and I
want to emphasize that I am neither a
tax policy expert nor an economist
although in 1994 I did win the bronze
medal in economics at the Alabama State
academic decathlon so for one brief
shining moment I was the third best
economist among all 17-year old C
students in the state of Alabama but I
recognize that's not expertise I have
however read a lot of experts okay so
both Donald Trump and Ted Cruz have
proposed tax reforms that will
dramatically simplify the American tax
code in fact Cruz has promised to make
taxation so straightforward that we
won't even need an Internal Revenue
Service anymore so let's start there
with his plan so right now in the u.s.
we have seven tax brackets so like if
you're married and filing jointly and
you made a million dollars last year
first off congratulations but as for
your taxes the first eighteen thousand
four hundred fifty of your million
dollars are taxed at 10% to the next
fifty six thousand four hundred forty
nine dollars are taxed at 15% etc with
everything over four hundred sixty five
ish thousand dollars taxed at the top US
marginal tax rate of 39.6% except not
actually because of deductions like if
you have a mortgage you can deduct the
interest you pay money you give to
charity can be deducted as well your
student loan interest might be
deductible some retirement savings some
child care costs lots of other stuff but
let's imagine an extremely unlikely
scenario where you're making a million
dollars a year but don't claim any of
these deductions you can still claim the
so called standard deduction this is a
tax deduction available to everyone if
you're married and filing jointly it's
currently twelve thousand six hundred
dollars per year so your first twelve
thousand six hundred dollars of income
wouldn't be taxed regardless in the end
with a million dollars of income taking
the standard deduction you'd pay around
340 3427 dollars in tax an effective tax
rate of like thirty four point three
percent the same family earning $250,000
a year would pay fifty three thousand
seven hundred fifty five dollars an
effective tax rate of twenty one point
five percent and if your family had the
median u.s. household income of around
fifty two thousand dollars you'd pay
just under five thousand dollars in
federal income taxes an effective tax
rate of about nine point six percent Ted
Cruz's plan is to collapse these seven
tax brackets into a single ten percent
tax rate for all income this is
sometimes called the flat tax crucially
Cruz would also increase the standard
deduction to $20,000 a year for married
couples filing jointly so the median
u.s. household income would end up
paying thirty two hundred dollars a year
in federal taxes instead of five
thousand a reduction of eighteen hundred
dollars or thirty four percent the
family making a million dollars a year
would pay ninety eight thousand dollars
a year in taxes a reduction of two
hundred forty five thousand dollars per
year or seventy two percent so everyone
would pay less tax but the wealthiest
Americans would see by far the biggest
cuts both in percentage and absolute
dollars Cruz would also eliminate most
of the affer mentioned tax deductions
except for mortgage interest and
charitable giving he would also
eliminate all federal gift and estate
taxes and repeal all corporate and
payroll taxes in favor of a 16% kind of
VAT which is where it gets really
interesting
insofar as this stuff can be interesting
by the way Europeans were like oh my god
he finally said a word I recognized that
kinda in most European countries there's
a broad tax on consumption called the
VAT or value-added tax Cruz's VAT is a
little different basically it taxes
businesses revenues minus their capital
investments and the money they pay to
other companies I'm going to
oversimplify here a little bit but
imagine I wanted to start a company
selling t-shirts that celebrated my love
of pizza that were available for twenty
dollars right now at dftba.com now
imagine that I had to pay a company ten
dollars to manufacture each t-shirt I
would only pay VAT on the ten dollar
difference the other company would pay
VAT on the ten dollars that I paid them
and then they would get to subtract any
non wage cost they incurred making the
shirt etc also if I wanted to buy my own
machine to make t-shirts I could
subtract the cost of that machine from
my revenue before paying the VAT the
money left over is either profit that
goes to owners or wages that go to
employees so basically it's a tax on
both wages and corporate profits and it
would aim to do a
better job than our current system does
have actually like taxing economic
activity which would be good because as
you might have heard with the current
system there's a fair bit of tax
avoidance going on lots of economist
although certainly not all of them liked
the idea of this kind of that but Cruz's
specific plan would dramatically reduce
the amount of federal revenue like the
nonpartisan Tax Policy Center calculates
that Cruz's plan would reduce federal
revenue by eight point six trillion
dollars over the next ten years now Cruz
says that by eliminating the IRS and a
few other federal agencies the
government can save five hundred billion
dollars over the next decade but that's
less than 10% of the shortfall like if
you ceased all military spending in the
United States you'd still be two
trillion dollars short but Cruz doesn't
want to eliminate military spending
instead he wants to increase it
dramatically now some economist argued
the shortfall will partly be made up by
increased economic growth but even the
most optimistic independent modeling I
could find still showed a dramatic
increase in the budget deficit under a
Cruz tax plan barring huge cuts to
either Medicare or Social Security or
some combination of the two
okay so then there's Donald Trump's plan
Trump would also increase the standard
deduction but by more so that any couple
making $50,000 a year or less would pay
no federal income tax and he would
collapse the seven tax brackets into
four with the top rate being 25% on
income over four hundred thirty two
thousand dollars per year Trump's plan
is similar to Cruz's and that he would
also eliminate gift and estate taxes and
most deductions but he would cut
corporate tax rates rather than replace
them with a vet which would probably
lead to a lot of people identifying as
corporations instead of human beings for
complicated reasons explained here if
you want to pause the video the other
facet of Trump's tax plan that he talks
a lot about on the campaign trail is
that currently hedge fund managers and
some other people who work in finance
can be paid in what's called carried
interest which allows them to pay a
lower tax rate and Trump's plan would
end this but because income tax rates
will be so low under the Trump plan
almost all hedge fund managers will pay
less tax than they do now while
campaigning Trump has also repeatedly
said that his tax plan will quote cost
me a fortune which is just not true
like under the trunk plan if you make a
million dollars a year you'll pay about
two hundred thousand dollars a year in
taxes which is much higher than under
the Cruz plan but much much lower than
the current rates but altogether Trump's
proposed tax plan would actually cost
the federal government more revenue than
Cruz's plans somewhere between ten and
twelve trillion dollars over the next
decade that's about like 25 percent of
the total federal budget he has
that his tax policy will be
revenue-neutral but in response to that
the right-leaning Center for federal tax
policy wrote an op-ed entitled Donald
Trump's tax plan will not be
revenue-neutral under any circumstances
the Tax Policy Center meanwhile
estimates that eliminating the United
States military altogether would cover
just about half of the revenue gap
created by Trump's tax plan
so in summary Ted Cruz's tax plan
involves a radical simplification of the
tax code a flat 10% income tax would
lead to lower taxes for all Americans
but the wealthy would benefit the most
and Cruz a strategy for revamping the
corporate tax code has support among a
lot of economists but the low rates
would lead to dramatically higher budget
deficits Trump's tax plan would probably
lead to even bigger deficits as with
Cruz's tax plan everyone would pay lower
taxes but the rich get the majority of
the benefit although Trump's tax plan
does not benefit the rich as much as
Cruz's does but more importantly neither
of these plans is at all feasible unless
we completely reimagine the role that
government plays in American lives
especially the lives of the elderly the
disabled and military veterans budget
cuts the services benefiting those
people are extremely politically
unpopular so much so that both
candidates have promised to find a way
to preserve those programs but to speak
frankly neither of these candidates has
offered a serious explanation for how
they would do that you simply cannot cut
government receipts by 20% while
preserving the programs that together
make up more than 80% of the budget Hank
I'll see you on Friday